we've had new ghosts of Tsushima combat
details marbles Avengers is offering a
free next-gen upgrade and cyberpunks
getting a comic book
I'm chastity and you've reached your
save save for Tuesday June 23rd if
you're as excited as I am to wield a
katana and ghost of Tsushima then this
one's for you
Sucker Punch gave us some new details
and went in-depth on the game's combat
there are some new ghosts of Tsushima
gameplay clips and a blog post that go
into detail about Jin's katana sucker
punch focused on speed sharpness and
precision in terms of speed attacks are
super fast in fact they had to be slowed
down from the motion capture because
they were too fast for players to react
to so enemies attack you fast but not
faster than you can actually handle some
enemy combo start with a slower attack
then a series of even faster ones the
mantra of development was respect the
katana devs didn't want an imbalance
where Jin could take more hits than the
enemy so both you and the enemies are
never more than a few mistakes away from
dying in real life it takes a long time
to master the timing and handling of
katana in the game you can cancel
attacks at any moment Sucker Punch says
that bailing out of an attack when you
see one coming your way is important to
high-level play you can also pull off a
perfect parry leaving enemies open to a
big counter-attack
also you can switch stances at any time
different stances work better on
different enemies as a reminder ghosts
of Tsushima is only out on ps4 on July
17th if you want to play Marvel's
Avengers as soon as possible but also
want to play it on a next-gen console
it's great news because Marvel's
Avengers is getting a free upgrade to PS
5 and series X best of both worlds now
confirmed by Square Enix if you buy the
game on ps4 or Xbox one you'll get the
PS 5 or series X version for free note
that Microsoft's smart delivery program
does this for all first party games but
third party dubs can make their own
choice the next-gen versions will have
enhanced features and you'll be able to
transfer your save file also the
PlayStation Blog listed some additional
ps5 features these include faster load
times higher resolution and better
textures haptic feedback via the dual
sense controller spatial audio and the
PS 5 will have enhanced graphics mode
and a high frame rate mode the first one
provides the highest resolution possible
and the second has you playing the game
at 60fps with a dynamic 4k resolution
as a reminder the Avengers war table
event takes place tomorrow June 24th at
10 a.m. Pacific 1 p.m. Eastern and will
include a new trailer new gameplay
details and new co-op details marvel's
avengers is out on ps4 Xbox one and PC
on September 4th but the next-gen
versions coming alongside the new
consoles this holiday we're all waiting
patiently for cyberpunk 2077 but great
news because in September we can still
get a slice of its world cuz cyberpunk
is getting a comic miniseries the first
issue of Dark Horse's cyberpunk 2077
trauma team arrives on September 9th
with three additional issues to follow
the first issue is four dollars and
thirty two pages a collection of all for
comics hasn't been announced the story
is set within the world of the game and
it follows a character called Nadia she
is the lone survivor in a botched rescue
by the trauma team she was part of
cyberpunk 2077 was delayed and the new
release date is November 19th on ps4
Xbox one and PC PS 5 and Series X
versions are confirmed but with no
release date and don't forget that
GameSpot is right in the middle of play
for all we're still raising money for
black lives matter and Kovan 19 relief
so check those donation links in the
description below we're hosting daily
charity livestreams at 12 p.m. Pacific
and 3 p.m. Eastern with plenty of
amazing guests tomorrow we're joined by
the last podcast on the left's Henry
Zebrowski and Marcus Parks Thursday
we're gonna Posse up with the cast of
Red Dead Redemption 2 and Friday we're
gonna play some rocket lead with Naomi
Kyle check out all our play for all
streams interviews and more right here
on GameSpot and that's your safe safe
for today I'm Cassidy and you can find
me on Twitter at Cassidy underscore V be
good to one another and take time for
self-care see you next time
[Music]